[Musique]
et
nous
[Musique]
quand je vais 17 faire un film qu'est ce
qui vous décide en paix
l'histoire et ckoi amoureuse
d'où sort une belle histoire vous voulez
dire une histoire qui change ou toujours
l'analyse fois
voilà qui change mais si vous demandez
ce que c'est qu'une belle histoire ça
serais incapable de vous répondre
les critères d'une belle histoire je ne
connais pas sauf que
je suis toujours cette phase 2 rbds 1 et
kim eun hye après longtemps le bon faire
un bon film rappelle toi d'une chose et
vous toujours deux ou trois choses plus
mon histoire
secundo de l'histoire et tertio une
histoire
[Musique]
vous allez rencontrer gamin
kabbaj le rencontrer quand j'ai fait mon
premier film vous avez toujours voulu je
me commence à commencer
[Musique]
coïncidence purement on est venu me
chercher j'ai dit non et humour
comme ici vous avez su vous êtes un
lecteur me le dire je savais pas qu est
ce qui est des gens qu'ils ont conseillé
à ce moment là mais ce que j'ai pu mener
la guerre tout ça vous savez je n'ai je
n'ai jamais
permis à qui que ce soit de décider au
milieu et placement moi j'ai jamais eu
deux
je n'ai pas d'agent je n'ai pas de mon
conseiller c'est moi vous êtes
extrêmement orgueilleux
peut-être
si c'est de l'orgueil tout est
c'est de leur donner beaucoup
je n'aime pas les jeux en bois c'est ce
que vous êtes toujours angoissé
seulement
ok
[Musique]
un oiseau quoi
la mort
[Musique]
quoi de l'avenir de lui tirer un film
jours d'hommages allons alors soit moche
que du beau monde
oui je sais que ça fait ça fait très
très très mal de dire ça en noir on doit
mourir de peur
le trac doivent louer les tripes je suis
désolé je l'est pas voilà je suis désolé
je suis un un pic entre up si vous
voulez mais je le départ puisqu'on ne
vous ne l'est pas je n'ai aucune
angoisse à ce sujet j'ai des doutes
j'ai le désir de bien faire j'ai le
désir de peindre tromper mais je n'ai
pas d'angoissé donc des ongles je suis
plutôt un comédien d'instinct comme ça
qu'est ce que vous appelez travailler je
veux dire à me torturer sur un rôle pour
savoir non non je ne sais pas que je ne
travaille pas c'est pas vrai c'est parce
qu'il faut dire injuste mais je ne me
tourmente pas je veux dire que dès le
départ si on me propose de main de fer
par exemple un certain rôle je moi moi
je sais que je vais pouvoir le faire où
je sais que je ne pourrai pas le faire
alors je fais pas ce sont des critères à
moi qui sont basés sur je ne sais pas si
vous voulez mais on ne peut pas le
forcer à faire quelque chose que j'ai
pas envie de faire ça c'est pas possible
cherchez des routes
[Musique]
m
j'aurais peut-être d'une façon
inconsciente ou peut-être vous avez
raison c'est pas seulement c'est vrai
que il ya des choses que je ne pourrai
jamais aussi sondé d'aider des principes
de morale peut être complètement idiot
des cieux un sculpteur se doit de tout
faire mais moi je sais qu'on ne leur ai
jamais je ne verrai jamais tenues entre
deux rois avec une arme pour le petit
filet
je laisse à d'autres enjeux ne sait pas
le faire
ni faire des personnages complètement
négatif c'est positif dans persona
oui parce que quand j'ai fait par
exemple deuxième souffle ou classe
touriste rf le doute est il ya bon
c'était des langues ster donc c'était
pas que j'ai une admiration sans borne
pour l'union exter mais il y avait
dedans des motivations humaines y avait
une idée midi face b et mystification
aussi mêmes
des mythes isation de ce genre là c'est
ça qui m'intéressait mais de faire
demain un sanguinaire un type qui tue
comme un lion d'or se traite à partir du
moment où je ne crois pas à quelque
chose j'ai très mauvais autrement dit je
suis un testament testard peu têtu
obture tête de cochon
vous êtes arrivé déjà ne vous être
on fait comme ça
tout le monde se trompe heureusement
baisse serait d'un ennui profond si on
avait la recette exacte précise de ce
que l'on doit faire des films que vous
regrettez d'avoir fait très peu
heureusement pour moi oui mais y en a je
me suis trompé comme toujours ce que
j'assume complètement ce que j'ai fait
c'était quoi l'erreur
à l'erreur l'erreur c'est qu'on ya cru
et puis que la mayonnaise n'a pas pris
mais il faut toujours avoir le doute les
gens qui n'ont pas le doute me terrifie
je suis terrorisée par là
manning alors quand je vois un type qui
met en scène molotov qui est beaucoup
plus inquiet que moi là je suis rassuré
est-ce que vous avez bien compris elle a
pas besoin d'un metteur en scène très
fort et vous avez besoin qu'on vous
respecte votre secteur
écoutez moi j'ai le plus vraiment léger
le plus profond respect pour les autres
mais je veux qu'on me respecte
je n'ai jamais appelé un garçon garçon
est toujours appelé monsieur mais il
faut pas me louper moi parce que sinon
ça peut aller très très loin ça peut
être très dangereux
j'ai la conception morale du mois je
n'ai jamais permis sur un plateau vous
savez il ya quelque chose qui est très
très fort elle insupportable pour moi je
veux dire que sous couvert de l'humilité
d'un seul coup parce que quelqu'un une
position à laquelle on peut pas toucher
dans ce coup se permet d'insulter
d'invectivés ou de traiter des gens très
mal ça c'est trop facile ça et ça je ne
vais jamais permis
j'ai eu quelques incidents à ce propos
même à tant que je serai sur un plateau
je me permettrai à personne il de
traiter des gens quels qu'ils soient
une certaine façon
ce que je trouve ça très lâche et ç'a
bien ce qu'on a peur de vous sur un
plateau ça ça me fait toujours sourire
parce que non non les je pense que les
billets équipes se soient les machines
les électro qui connaissent depuis des
années au contraire on est très copain
est vraiment sont des gens vous savez à
qui on ne peut pas en une chose ils sont
tous vus en tout connu bon on m'a dit
qu'il y avait des fois des gens qui est
un timide et c'est moi ça me fait
sourire parce que moi j'y crois pas je
me dis mais alors quoi est-ce que je
suis une brute à neutre alors me dit oui
mais tu te vois pas content il faut à
tout comme ça non halal gélinas mais je
suis je sais pas je m'en veux
et pourtant envoyé moi je fais tout je
pense que je fais tout pour ne pas
l'être
[Musique]
j'avais beaucoup de scripts énormément
malheureusement elles sont pas
c'est très difficile a pas d'expliquer à
succès
voulait dire qu'en trois ans j'ai perçu
un script qui que vous trouviez
satisfaisant non non bah sinon je
l'aurais pris
[Musique]
j'avais l'angoissé quelques fois qu'on
vous désire plus
je me suis tellement préparés
[Musique]
que je dois dire sincèrement non je n'ai
pas cette angoisse voilà et puis j'en
avais toujours l'habitude de me dire
cette phrase il me disait dis toi bien
qu'à chaque fois que tu fais un film
c'était ce dernier que tu fais ce métier
fait ainsi
demain si ça se trouve lino ventura
ennuiera profondément la terre entière
donc c'est pas pour mais ça sera comme
ça je pense qu'on est plus rien
vous ne serez pas troubler ses blessés
n'ont certainement pas peut-être triste
peut-être par moments mais en bois s'est
blessé n'ont donc certainement pour
toute franchise on faire un premier film
de metteur en scène vous posons tous
agen
pierre n'a eu que 20
qui bat commencer par claude sautet à
commencer par
j'étais pas tout tous les garçons que je
vous citez tout à l'heure si ce n'était
pas le premier mois c'était le deuxième
mais que ce soit
il faut enfin tout où toute la clique de
ce qu'on appelait les 'grands assistant
de l'époque s'était pas senti mes films
non il avait déjà fait un chef-d'oeuvre
qui s'appelait la rivière duigou et
réunion disant nous allons balla non
banon non là vous avez raison c'était
moi je ne les connais pas
je suis un peu un peu perdue j'ai
l'impression d'être un fossile de
rapport à certains jeux met en scène une
équipe connais pas mais peut-être que
moi je ne les intéresse pas du tout je
suis peut-être un matériau qui
n'utilisent pas moi je le connais pas
enfin c'est parce qu'ils ont peur
d'aller vers vous donc c'est faux parce
que je reçois beaucoup de choses de
jeunes 1 mais peur quand vous appelez
toujours ce goût de peur c'est étrange
ou devrais je me balade avec un poignard
entre les dents et des grenades dans les
mains mais je vous fais peur
[Musique]
c'est vraiment super fan